we're here in the San Francisco Bay
model visitors center where you have a
chance to see the only operational
hydraulic working model in the United
States today
the primary purpose in building the
model was to test the John River plan
John River wanted to Dam the bay he
wanted to build two freshwater
reservoirs by constructing two large
dams one were the bay bridges and one of
the San Rafael Richmond bridges after
the construction of the bay model in 54
to 57 and all the tests of his theory
and his idea it was summarily rejected
fortunately for all of us we probably
wouldn't have a San Francisco Bay today
after the construction of the model it
was used as a scientific operational
research test facility from 1954 until
January of 2000 scientists could predict
impacts on oil spills major storms but
mostly the impact of man-made projects
on any part of the shoreline the San
Francisco Bay model represents about
1,600 square miles of land and water
resources about 70 miles inland from the
coast of California the Pacific Ocean is
built all on sand but the entire rest of
the model and the Delta are built out of
concrete slabs was about 286 of them
they're 12 foot squares they weigh about
7 tons each and they're all elevated
about 30 to 38 inches up off of the
floor
we have two supercomputers and also a
lot of very sophisticated technology and
a little facility called the tide Hut
every morning when we turn on the
computer it takes about 20 to 21 minutes
to flood the entire model and the Delta
with about 135,000 gallons of water at
the end of the day at four o'clock and
we closed to the public we closed the
system down all the water drains back
into the sump tank you'll see it
throughout the model there's about
250,000 copper tabs they're embedded in
the concrete and their primary purpose
is to help provide frictional resistance
to help create the right tides and
currents there's three specific criteria
that important and analyzing how the
model is calibrated and how it operates
the horizontal scale the model is the
thousand to one so for every thousand
feet underneath the Golden Gate Bridge
one foot in the model the vertical scale
is a hundred to one so for every hundred
feet underneath the Golden Gate Bridge
one foot down in the model but the most
important factor is time now a lunar day
is like 24 hours 54 minutes so many
seconds but in the bay model that
happens every fourteen point nine
minutes so every fourteen point nine
minutes of a model you have two high
tides and two low tides mathematically
changing but every three point seven
eight minutes
the area of the bay model what we call
the San Francisco Bay mall Bay model
delta area this represents about 1,600
square miles it's about the size of the
state of Rhode Island when you're
standing on our observation deck looking
down at the bay model it's about the
same as flying in an aircraft above the
city of San Francisco at an altitude of
about 10 to 12,000 feet looking down at
the bay